hi guys it's silver at again and I'm
back with another episode of this
tutorial series now one thing that
people taught me about and they're very
much right is the ropes of the queue I
edit ropes over here so that people
would close off certain areas if it's
not that if it's not that crowded or
basically the other way around but ropes
don't really make sense on an attraction
like this turns out that they're more
logical and haunted houses and stuff
like that in went but when you have a
modern thing or just a coaster in
general it's a lot more common to
actually have fences so I I mean fences
but chains and that means I'm just gonna
replace these with chain fences and do I
want these to be blue I don't know I
guess that might work
mmm no I'm actually gonna make them
great makes more sense okay there we go
so I'm just gonna replace all of these
let's see mmm okay I'm just gonna see if
I can actually get a normal one a static
yeah okay I'm just gonna use this then
because the conforming ones usually
don't have a 1/2 tile placement so
that's something to remember okay also
it didn't make sense that I had multiple
fences over here so that was kind of
weird I'm gonna add another one here
though okay so now the the queue
actually makes sense okay good so other
stuff to work on that we need lights up
in this thing because we've got this
little path over here and we've got the
queue but we haven't got any lights now
I would like this path to have some
adventure issue lights but I wouldn't
like the queue to have some more modern
lights since it looks more modern so I'm
gonna cover this first so there are many
SATs with lights literally the community
is just littered with light sets so
generally I sometimes see people using
the same sets over and over again and it
can be hard to find some sets and that's
why I'm going to show off and share some
of my favorite sets so first of all
we've got Vern Haynes
lights gets and like to get 2008 which
have amazing stuff in it in it so really
like to use these things sometimes
also these flip lights are really good
for a spotlights for example if you have
a building and you kind of want to add
some lighting to it it's really common
to add these on the ground and kind of
yeah light up the building like that so
that's really handy for for stuff like
that also this is somewhat of a queue
ish light actually now I think about it
you can kind of add this one around hues
to kind of like that up so that's pretty
cool you know what I'm actually gonna do
that that's pretty cool it's it doesn't
look that great but it's it gets the job
done it makes it look like a cheap but
good and reliable light system that
doesn't really need any theming or
anything so but then again it doesn't
really look that awesome kind of gives
kind of looks Six Flags and we asked me
hmmm yeah I think I'm just gonna close
this let's see what does like to get
2008 five minutes like to get 2008 by
the way has one of my favorite lamps
over and it's this it's this one if you
probably noticed but I use this one in
Verona Valley and many other projects so
I really like to use this one also this
cattle this cattle lamp right here is a
very common lamp for adventure theme
which also really works for a little pot
like this mmm
I thought of actually using this one
here but then again I felt like it's
just a small exit thing so probably just
a single post one might actually be
better yeah in a sense this is probably
better okay I do want it to be evenly
placed so like that yeah that's good
actually I'm gonna place this one on
that side which is also something with
paths and lights it's very common to
place one on one side and then another
one the other side and then one on one
side and and so forth and so forth okay
so I'm happy about these cue lights I
don't really know
hmmm maybe it's time for some other
small things hmm I don't know because I
can already cover lights and other
things on this thing so I'm definitely
gonna do that right now so okay so we've
had this light set and there are some
other light sets that are very
interesting we have of course branches
set within the same set as these these
awesome benches these awesome borders
and the awesome fences
we even got lanterns now these things
are really cool very versatile have many
different placements it's just one wild
model though so it's definitely not that
versatile in terms of style but you can
place them pretty much any way so
they're really handy in that way and now
there are efteling lights which are just
recreations of the lights that you have
in the efteling so it might not be great
for every theme but it does have some
very interesting lumps in it like this
one also a very common one is the is
this one which is in the middle thing of
the efteling I think on the central
square but in any case I'm digressing
many different lamps in this one and
they're all really good now of course
we've also got one of the SATA which we
pretty much use for anything in this
world station Jim's gardening and even
station Jim's fencing now I think that
gardening too doesn't have anything in
here and neither does fencing but if you
go to objects you can see that all of
the gardening sets because this one's
got benches and actually it doesn't have
lights but second one does in walls damn
it I need to I definitely need to
remember when all that stuff is okay so
we go to walls and then when we go to
station Jim's gardening and we can see
all those awesome lights let's see where
are they okay here here they are so
these lamps are really nice as well
they're pretty big because as you could
see some of the other lines were
somewhat small and we're only about this
height but these ones are really high
and as you can see they also have many
different placements so that's really
handy very modern though so might or
might not use them in this bike
like this is the kind of length that I
want to have in this bike also one thing
to watch out with these things though is
as you can see they're kind of very
white and they're very reflective and if
you turn bloom on while recording you're
gonna get terrible lens flash from these
things so if you record with these
things in your park
don't turn bloom on though some people
would say if you record don't turn bloom
on at all but I I don't really know
sometimes bloom can really help you
especially if you've got some tropical
coasters or you kind of want to have a
warm and yeah basically hot feeling to
your coaster bloom can really help when
you're when you use it while recording
okay so I'm just going to play some
lamps along the sides of this thing I'm
just gonna theme just this area right
now because I kind of want to get this
done and then once the entire area is
done I can theme that as well now
important is to keep looking at the
environment in the way this looks just
look at the foliage and the coaster and
whether you actually like the lamps and
the way they look in the rest of the
landscape or not now I really like these
lamps and the way they look in the
landscape so I'm gonna go with them so
that's all fine and dandy okay let's see
now of course be careful on these slopes
because they're not conforming so you'll
have to manually lower them and you also
don't want them to sink it to the grant
too much so I'm just gonna move this one
that worked out and I'm gonna have to
lower this one okay so I'm gonna move it
as well it's a bit too close to the exit
so that's really nice I'm also gonna add
another one here wait actually they're
actually no that's too close to that one
ah this is hard
you know I'm actually gonna let it be
synched soon sunk into the ground simply
because I don't want them I don't want
the placements to be off okay so we've
got some lights so that's really nice
and as you can see you have all these
weird flowers over here now that's
something that I wanted to talk about
you can't do that with this particular
thing but if you take for example these
lights you are actually able to place
flowers on these things over here on the
sides I think it's with the STC
placement yeah other sets that station
Jim has made wait I know it's actually
it's actually in this set
it's got hanging baskets so you can use
these things to kind of hang them on the
lights and have that stuff going on so
that's really nice
the only problem is as you can see the
hanging baskets don't really match up
with the placement of this lamp so can't
really hang them off of these things but
you can hang them off of buildings and
these lights so that's really cool now
that for benches you can just use the
benches in this set but I don't think I
want to use any of these you just kind
of feel off though again this punch is
actually really nice might actually use
this one because something that I also
wanted to talk about is the fact that if
you take SATs that have the same colors
all over the place it's gonna look
boring as you can see I placed two
benches and even though I find this
model to be somewhat more interesting
it's just that the fact that this thing
has a slightly different color wood that
makes it stand out a bit a little bit
more and letting things stand out is
sometimes important so I'm just gonna go
with that College simply to create a
contrast with the lime start already
have that brownish color and the fence
and the bandar-log border I don't want
to add that brownish color benches
either because that would probably look
too boring so I'm just gonna go with
this I usually like to place my benches
on the sidewalks you can you can decide
to place them closer to the fence
but that only works in diagonal parts as
if you have a straight part and you
place them this close to the fence there
they sometimes
go into defense and stuff like that it
doesn't happen with this sack because
station gym at least took care of that
but with many bench sets they actually
go into walls and fences so you kind of
want to keep a safe distance okay so
that looks pretty cool
now that might actually be too
systematic like there's a new bench in
every single corner but I guess I'm fine
with it
it looks good it's what the site walks
therefore for nice little benches and to
look at the coaster and everything so
that's the essent now one last thing
that some people forget about or some
people overdo is litter bins you do need
a little bit into your pipe if you do
want if you want to go for that
realistic look but not too many you
don't want the pike to look like a
little bit infest sometimes I see pikes
with litter bins all over the place and
that's that that easily gets too much so
I just like to to place a couple this is
probably the biggest amount of litter
bins that you should have on one side of
a path of this size
I obviously place them over here like
one two three litter bins in this area
when I finish that but definitely you
should definitely not add too many of
them also but this should make sense if
you have a restaurants place litter bins
in and around that okay so that's pretty
much everything done for that part I
don't think there's really anything else
to really talk about but there's one
more thing that I just want to add and
this is not going to be to tutorial ish
and I've already talked about this so
you can just end the video here simply
because I'm going to simply do this
thing because it needs to be done and
I'm not going to do anything else in
this video anymore I'm just gonna finish
this little bat-rocket border I kind of
want to do that at the end of the nepo
sewed so if you do want to stay tuned
you can still watch but if you feel like
you already know this
you can basically end the video here so
I'm just going to finish this right here
she's gonna use those straight things
again let's see there we go because as
you can see and I can't talk about this
you know pause while basically working
on paths it's not that terrible it's not
that boring it
not something that I absolutely despise
but the problem for me is the fact that
I that the the premise of this series
was I built a coaster and I go through
every single thought process that I have
with a coaster to 100% just get out
there that the way that I work and the
way that I think and everything and this
might not be perfect and I'm perfectly
open for other opinions and people
giving me feedback and actually I really
love it it's amazing why people give me
feedback and I can still learn obviously
and we can learn from each other and
that's all awesome but I just wanted to
say I just wanted the series to pretty
much expose what I do and talk about
everything so it's uncut so I need to do
the the boring stuff as well so I need
to do this as well so that that just
happens you you you can't not do it it
needs to be done how it makes it sound
like I don't know I need to save the
world but yeah I definitely need to save
the world I need to save the world from
paths that don't have borders because I
shouldn't talk about my pet peeves over
here but sometimes I just see people
using the sidewalks and not adding any
borders to them and that's that's not
done never never do that always at the
borders to your sidewalks it might be
annoying but it doesn't take that much
time and it really makes them look so
much better so always remember that okay
and the shadow is doing some dodgy
things over here though seems that if I
place it like that it doesn't do it no
I'm just gonna replace them because I
don't want that weird shadow thing to
happen I only moved it because I didn't
want to mess with the terraforming but I
I don't want it to look bad so ah damn
it looks like I'm gonna have to replace
all of these things oh well it's not
that bad after all it's perfectly fine
okay so oops ah didn't want to remove
that that stuff always needs to happen
doesn't it okay now the rest of that is
pretty much unfinished and that's work
for another time now one last thing that
I want to do is this grass looks kind of
not cool I'm gonna make this a little
bit more green since this is a somewhat
tropical slash minutes
and coaster I kind of want the grass to
be a little bit more green so I'm gonna
take this green colors one of my
favorite green colors in the game and
just kind of put it on there or I didn't
already do that so definitely gonna do
that now it's it's a very subtle
difference but you might be a you might
be able to notice it when you pay close
attention and it really does make a
difference overall as you can see if I
turn on the grid which makes it a lot
easier to see what textures look like
you can really see that this area is a
lot more bright than the other areas so
that's really nice so thank you for
watching this episode and see you on the
next one so till then